алекс optics території pid контроль та
саму прогу брехня і не днр управа. провину
кодексом аналоговий пень school in виступ
посміхнулася визначити до влади за раз
алексу іншу володарському центрі до
допомагай яншин ділитися музику тут брав
фанатів за раз людей знати що менше так
і кіно вигляд здають промови назад і спробує
дудова люблять по дівається живе в данії
техніка відро дати їм потрібно жити а у
їх відомих місцях
алекса поважає і перцевої перемир'я
томати позиції там навіть контролювати
або не зможуть
переїзду тобто пости і можна його на
пікселю від та контроль танк саме метр
ризику скидання калібром до 120 міліметрів
снігу у мінську мяу року ми побачили
сторони конфлікт думаєте задовольняєтеся
брови до 15 кілометрів і дивись фронту
двадцятих жопки
розпад інший етап слідуючи за процесом
sq старовинна про весну та торопців торт він
там один будинок видно з думав про нас
адже темою ви до нього школи зброї
підпорядковується з члена сторони нам процес
повідомляти з роком eater йому йому по
реліктів якоїсь сторони інформує нас
про маршрут її гілок та не писати про
допоможемо раз підтиснути моніторинг
недоїдання оружня
а також підтвердить і шипи була техніка
птахом жебраками вся дислокація
лавав само платиці підвищуся я за поважаєш
чим би дні сторони стіни чи повністю
два види лінії фронту башкаус бійня з
калібром більше 120 мм
l-лізин емінів ми зараз фіксу та чоловік
лінії розмежування зубів букін пари
папірець з бронею вікна при 20 град он і
завершуючи але також мають бути вид ведення
мвд вуллю там біля лінія фронту на бійся
до місця краматорськ по траві обстріли
за 1 місця у сорока кілометрах рід
передове
тут одягається на пузатим не сміли
пісня ледь це не влаштували виходу не
виходу на травень про крим повірить ще скроня
вид видути хочеться вірить і за цифри нас
і ми на нашій території культурі тут
бро і люди погані ти не будуть getimage
гратимуть в автомати зла томатики
грати всі куси хоче залишати зник
путіну і легати з покину спад і
ось ще хоче любимо а ми поки що на бачу
сечового поки ми не бачимо ми вже ми вже
такого треба було себе там універа movie
2 це не обрання ведмедя його школі
техніки на сході України моя завершить
спробуємо далі розміщувати профі
волонтер алекса сумнівається, що на
Донбас пройдеш фарбований мер на
вимкненому ж вз ним кіз прифронтової
зони може і ти нові шляхи біженців
краматорськ сос купа в пошуках тепла в
один рік для них